my hobby is being a physician
and it's good for your well-being
to do
something that you really love doing
because it's good for you in your
personal life it's good for you
as a physician and good for me as a as a
manager
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
let's talk about the future of medicine
meet assaf tokyo the ceo of matriself an
israeli biotechnology company that
regenerates the future of medicine
developing tissues and organs from the
patient's own bio material
[Music]
asaf tokyo welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
how are you very good how are you doing
i'm doing well uh because we are gonna
talk about some things that are very
uplifting and
truly are making a positive impact on on
people whether it's kids whether it's
people with
with different diseases and different
disabilities and
ways in which technology is shaping
healthcare and the way that we treat
patients in general and
you yourself you have you have a
fascinating personal background and
you know motivation with everything that
you're doing and whether it's with your
work as a
pediatrician whether it's work with
hospitals business development with vcs
and startups and in the biotech space
it's just fascinating all around and and
so in this conversation i would love to
both hear a little bit about your
personal mindset and your career
trajectory and because it's not trivial
and then a little bit about match
yourself and how you're using technology
to to really reshape health care and so
stop thank you very much for being here
sure looking forward
tell me about yourself as a doctor you
know what what does being a doctor for
you entail because it's something that
you've
kept no matter no matter what you've
done else professionally you always kept
being a doctor
sure so um
for me as a as a pediatrician
it's always uh
amazes me that you're not only treating
the kid
which is usually
you know a small kid who doesn't
you who cannot tell you what is feeling
and you need to uh
to basically
guess
and examine
and
try to figure out what's bothering him
you're also treating
the parents
sometimes the grandparents
and uh
the whole deal
is very fascinating because
you basically uh
treat two in a price of one
because you treat both
both sides and uh
and most of the time it's not uh you
know we're not doing
resuscitations every day and we're not
uh treating
some critically uh
kids fortunately enough but even when a
kid comes with a running nose
and
the parents are very worrying and
by giving a small
gesture or
telling something nice and you see that
they are going out with a smile on their
faces
you understand that you did a good a
good job
the reward is quite fast with kids
you see them smile very fast and you
know they they hug you and uh
it's it's something else it's it's not
like being a
uh adult
physician
and uh you can also be
you know you can make full of yourself
which is
you know when you treat an adult and you
do this for example
nobody understand why you they think
you're crazy but when i do this for a
kid
uh
you know he sees he says there's
something
ordinary something it sounds like
there's something very uh
very humane
about treating kids that you're
describing beyond the work beyond the
impact it's just it's very humane
yeah it's it's humane and
and by the way you can be a kid
yourself
when you treat so it's a it's a fun work
i really love it i love it and and
you've kept you've kept this work you
know even though you've done other
incredible things
whether it's working as an executive
within hospitals as vice president
whether it's being in the vc's
startup manager
you still kept that and and obviously it
takes away focus you know it's it's an
incredible thing you're helping kids but
it takes away focus yet you're you're
still making sure that you're dedicating
yourself to continue doing that in
parallel with other things and not
losing that
that work why so why is that
beyond the positive impact that it makes
why why why still do it
i think that it does me it makes me
a better
physician
and it also makes me a better manager
because
you know some people goes to uh to do
running as a hobby
some people do do a
judo or
playing uh
the piano
my hope is being a physician
and it's good for your well-being
to do
something that you really love doing
because it's good for you in your
personal life it's good for you
as a physician and good for me as a as a
manager
and there's a side product apart from
what i said uh all my employees
they have a
pediatrician
so uh
they can consult me whenever they have a
question on their kids and uh
it's a it's an advantage that no uh
not
not existing in many companies
i love it that that's a great uh that's
a great point
and so
transitioning from the the impact that
you're having on an individual and very
humane level
on your one-on-one interactions with the
patients you're working on much yourself
which is
really leveraging technology and very
interesting technology to reshape
in some way
um
you know different treatments of people
and so tell me a little bit about match
yourself and and how you've
sort of pa paved your way to this
company
so mate itself is a tissue engineering
and
opposed to other companies that usually
use synthetic materials
as their matrix
or
allogeneic cells meaning cells from a
different donor
for their cellular part of the
tissue
matter itself
is building tissues
in which both the cells
and the matrix are coming from the
patient themselves
so uh in our
implants
there is basically no immune response
which is a very very
important problem
in uh organ implants
and uh
and we believe that we are solving it
um
we are building can you tell me a little
bit more about this problem about about
immune response because and with very
little understanding from my end but
essentially what you're talking about is
the ability for our immune system to
accept
tissues that are not created originally
by us right sure
when
when you
expose the human body
to a foreign object
uh
the response of the human
immune system is basically to attack
this foreign object and therefore people
that are undergoing
uh transplant
any transplant of any organ usually take
uh immunosuppressant
and what matter self is doing different
is that we are developing complete
autologous implants
in which the whole implant
is originated from the human the
patient's own biomass
so
when you use your own biomass there is
no immune response to this implants
and therefore you don't need to take to
take immunosuppressants and the
probability
of those implants to be accepted by the
body
are uh much more higher
and so obviously
this is
ideal but it hasn't been done until now
for for various reasons what what are
what are some contributing reasons to
the complexity
of of what you're building here so most
companies used a
synthetic materials
for their scaffolds
and we managed to build
a scaffold
on which the cells actually build the
tissue
that is originated from the patient
themselves
and taking this
with the cellular part that we are also
building from the patients
on cells
we basically managed to build a an
implant that is
fully originated from the patient
himself
and
for the first time
we are offering
a complete 3d
functioning
autologous tissue
and it is a platform we can basically
create any tissue that we would like to
create
and the first indication that we are
taking to the market is spinal cord
injury
which unfortunately has a huge market
there are
thousands of patients with
spinal cord injury usually due to a
traumatic accident
and we are basically building
neural implants that will replace the
damaged tissue in the spine
and
hopefully will help those patients to
regain
both motor sensor
and autonomic functions
something that uh
again unfortunately
no other company managed to uh
to uh to solve
so it's a huge market
very
expensive for healthcare systems
and unfortunately with no solutions
so if we're
right now taking a step back and we're
saying
where are we at right now with our
ability as humans to treat patients
let's say with spinal cord injuries
right so there's a variety of different
things that that can be done most of
them my understanding is that they're
very limited in the way that they
actually treat
where how how close are we from a
technological standpoint in your eyes to
to reaching something
that can actually be meaningfully
treated
with with our technology so whether it's
with microsoft or something else where
are we in this landscape of technology
and humans and let's say spinal cord
injuries or any other form of such
disease so where are we do you think
so for many years
many companies tried
to solve this problem and unfortunately
we're not successful
but as time progresses we believe that
we get more and more knowledge
on how the nervous system works on one
hand
and now to try and
solve
the problems that were previously
related to those uh
trials
for example uh one of the problems is
that in the area of the
injury
there is basically a scar tissue that
prevents from the neural signaling
to pass through the wire to the through
the spinal cord
and uh
there are companies that are trying to
bridge this
electronically
and uh there are other companies that
are trying cellular
and tissue therapies
and we are one of of the companies that
are trying tissue
implants
basically after taking out the scarring
tissue
building a new
neural tissue that will basically
substitute
the damaged tissue
so
i personally believe that uh
we are on our way
to change the lives of
thousands and millions of patients
all over the world and again
for a quadriplegic patient
to be able to uh to take out his iphone
and text somebody
or to be able to to eat by himself
it's a game changer not saying
other
uh functions like uh urinating by
themselves or uh even walking
this will be a true game changer in
spinal cord injury
obviously i mean at the end
you're touching on some such fundamental
human need of you know being being
autonomous being independent and being
able to to to live into and to function
um such such a fundamental thing that we
sometimes maybe forget that we we're
taking it for granted but
if we're looking now on a scale level so
you're mentioning that
one thing that gets you excited about
match yourself is the fact that this
really
does have the potential to make an
impact on many many lives and so how do
we transition from
a research or an idea to a full-on
product that works with hospitals with
clinics and you know the space because
you've been an executive at a hospital
you've you are a pediatrician what what
is the gap that you now have to overcome
as the as an entrepreneur
from the research to the production
so first of all we have a proof of
concept in animals
which is a
a good start
and then
last year we did a prion d meeting with
the fda
to basically uh present our
r d program
and get their feedback so we aligned our
r d program according to this prion d
meeting
and
we have a roadmap we are following our
roadmap
uh
doing all the
necessary trials and animal trials
towards the first human clinical trial
that are currently planned for the
beginning of 2025
and
with
with a great technology
and more importantly
or you know
at least as equal
an amazing team
of uh
scientists that are coming here every
morning
uh with a lot of motivation
that is coming from patients
that are coming to our offices or
sending us emails
looking forward for our success
we truly believe that we are going to
change the world
i love it
from a leadership perspective
managing mentioning you're 11 people
strong now with my true self
what is sort of the makeup of this group
what what what kind of family did you
create here
that that is working on this problem
with you
so first of all eight out of the eleven
are uh
women
so we believe in
girl power
uh we have
amazing team
of both r d personnel
uh lab employees
uh financials
operational
so we we created a small team that is
you know it's like our second family
most of the
awake hours
we are here together
and uh
i
i truly believe that once you create
an elite team
that works together
and more important
have fun
doing it
you have uh
a major part of the road to success
right and obviously with it with the
challenges that that i've been hearing
about throughout the podcast you know
this this this small cohort at the end
you know it has to grow and you have to
start figuring out okay what how is this
thing expanding
what are the you know serious culture
that we want to to have
what are the things that we are willing
to compromise a little bit or to change
naturally
but but but it is fascinating now
you know just to to wrap up
my understanding of you a little bit so
you know pediatrician
vc
executive at hospital and startup
entrepreneur
is there is there a common thread in
your eyes
to the way that you're choosing to spend
your career
it's not it's not traditional to go
through so many of these different
adventures is there you know a common
thread that resonates to your own
personality
um
i always
tell to my kids
that in your last day
here
you should look in the mirror
and say to yourself that you
were
first of all
a good person
[Music]
and second of all that you had fun
and i tried to do it i tried
very hard to be a good person
and
i tried to
to have fun
living the life working my my
career
and i tried to choose on
adventures that are
combining those two
i love it
really thank you so much this was
so enjoyable and uh and fascinating and
best of luck with my true self and and i
love the
the theme
of of being a good person and having fun
and that obviously resonates to all the
different positions you've also held and
you can look you can look at every
position you're you're a good person and
you're having fun and
obviously i can i can see
how you are
bringing that energy with you to
everything that you do so it's
fascinating and i'm sure that it's very
enjoyable by a lot of the people that
are working with you in your
organization so thank you very much and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much you too
[Music]